hello from canada
i'm sure you're aware of the insanity we
are going through i feel like canada is
one of the test territories for the
global plan am i just paranoid am i
losing it do you still think there's a
way out of this thank you so much from
the you guys are punk rock guy which you
are
yeah there
there are ways out of this
we are going to have to stand up we're
going to have to rise up against
these officials who whatever the
explanation are completely botching the
response to the pandemic and they are
putting us in a great deal of danger and
not just us but our children
and
yeah canada
is ahead of the u.s
australia appears to be ahead of the us
in terms of the tyrannical nonsense
and
you know the the u.s has not yet played
its role in becoming part of the
resistance but really it's all tied up
in there
i think the
the fundamental difference between this
and
prior outbreaks of tyranny is that
because this one's global in some sense
the resistance movement has to be as
well
and uh anyway don't give up hope yes
we are we are going to find ourselves
in battle and it's one that we have to
win
next question
the situation is deteriorating fast in
canada is it futile to think we can
still live our lives without being
vaccinated what will it take to break
the fear spell thank you both very much
we missed you
well i i
at one level the fact the vaccines
aren't doing any of the things they were
supposed to do at some point should get
noticed by someone but it doesn't seem
to be getting noticed no but it's worse
it's worse right the the evidence is
actually mounting that these vaccines
make you more likely to contract the
disease the idea that that has not
caused our governments to say wait a
second hold on with the vaccines
something has changed let us figure out
what it is we'll be back to you in a
minute right that's what a rational
government would do the fact that it was
like nope hey the advice we gave you
just so happens to still be the right
advice in fact
even though in fact it's obviously
upside down
that tells you whoa i can't afford to
listen to that person if that person
tells me to ingest something i ought to
wonder if it's a poison right yeah so
i would you know can you continue to
live unvaccinated
look i'm not advising you to do anything
but i would say your government
has betrayed you and it has failed to do
what it promised it could do if you
think that that failure is on people who
have not complied then look into
gibraltar
right the fact is their one remedy does
not work so in light of that
can you afford to take their advice and
just grin and bear it how many times
will they force you to be boosted
right they are exposing you to danger
each time they do that so
in some sense as appalling as what is
going to happen to you if you resist is
how appalling is what's going to happen
to you if you don't resist you don't
know it could be ten years from now that
you find out the answer to that question
so i would just your feet then die on
your knees yeah exactly uh exactly
you want you want to repeat that i think
it broke up with skype
oh better it's better to live on your
feet than to die on your knees this from
the old man in the whorehouse in catch
22 an excerpt that we read from
some weeks ago
yep it's it's the right answer and um
you know i i don't think i owe anybody
an apology but i feel like offering one
i'm sorry it's that stark right i'm
sorry that that's where we are in
history and that that means that you
have to make some awful choice but
that's the nature of history
[Music]